[MUSIC]
The NLM culture I could characterize
as diverse--lots of opportunities--
and also very family friendly.
The very remarkable thing about NLM is
the diversity of the workforce in every
sense, you know, whether it's age or their
professional training or their culture.
Here people are very approachable, and if
you don't mind, you just...even though you
think that, you know, oh they are the Head
of this department or whatever...you're kind
of afraid of them, but don't be so because I
found whoever I tried to talk to,
they seldom turned me down.
To me the culture is self-driven, always
strives for excellence.
NLM is full of very hardworking,
dedicated people who are passionate
about providing biomedical information.